[Musik]
die Koalition gerettet oder das Land
einen guten Abend liebe Zuschauer
Donnerstagabend im zweiten nach dem Ende
des koalitionsmarathons sieht der
Kanzler ein großes Werkstück gelungen
dass Deutschland auf Jahrzehnte
verändern wird viele Kritiker sehen in
der Einigung allerdings eher Stückwerk
bei den vielen Fragen und Streitpunkte
offen bleiben zum Beispiel die
Finanzierung der neuen Heizungen nach
den querellen der letzten Woche könnte
man sogar daran zweifeln das und wie
lange diese Ampel noch durchhält wir
fragen und wir müssen reden mit diesen
Gästen
der Bundesfinanzminister und FDP-Chef
Christian Lindner
der SPD-Vorsitzende Lars Klingbeil
der Vorsitzende von Bündnis 90 die
Grünen
Eva Quadbeck Chefredakteurin
redaktionsnetzwerk Deutschland
und der Leiter des zdf-hauptstadt
Studios Theo Paul
sie sind zu Gast bei Maybrit Illner
[Musik]
und alle sind ausgesprochen herzlich
begrüßt drei Tage Koalitionsausschuss
die Ampel feiert einen Durchbruch und
andere sehen eine ausgemachte
Regierungskrise
Nachtsitzungen wollte man sich
eigentlich ersparen es wurde eine und
ein ganzer Tag dazu und noch ein Tag und
nicht jede steht am Ende als Gewinnerin
da ich will ganz ehrlich sein reicht das
was du beim Klimaschutz drin steht nein
vor allem beim Verkehr bleibt eine große
Lücke die Konflikte waren zum Streit
ausgewachsen auf offener Bühne über
Wochen wärmewende verbrennerverbot
Autobahnausbau diese Ampel schien nichts
mehr zusammenzuhalten wir haben ganz
offensichtlich in Deutschland eine
Regierungskrise Christian Lindner sagt
der Gipfel waren drei gut investierte
Tage Lücken im Koalitionsvertrag sein
geschlossen worden Deutschland vor einem
Paradigmenwechsel
das ist kein Wumms das ist schon gar
kein doppelwumms das ist glaube ich
nicht mal ein wimsschen den Kanzler
fischt das nicht an er wähnt sich im
temporrausch der Stillstand der letzten
Jahrzehnte den wir konservativer Politik
zu verdanken haben ist endgültig beendet
wirklich es ist noch keine zehn Tage her
dass der Vizekanzler am Stillstand
seiner zwei Koalitionspartner
verzweifelte
es kann aber nicht sein dass in einer
fortschrittskoalition nur einen
Koalitionspartner für den Fortschritt
verantwortlich ist und die anderen für
die Verhinderung von Fortschritt
und wir begrüßen Eva Quadbeck die
Chefredakteurin des redaktionsnetzwerkes
Deutschland Frau Quadbeck war das eine
erste echte Regierungskrise und ist sie
vorbei also das war eine Regierungskrise
aus meiner Sicht keine existenzielle
also ich habe zu keinem Zeitpunkt
angenommen dass die Ampel über diesen
Streit um die Energiepolitik platzen
könnte aber ja wenn man drei Tage so
zusammen sitzt und am Ende ja ein Papier
bekommt mit dem längst nicht alle
zufrieden sind und wo auch sehr
ersichtlich ist dass da auch sehr viel
Machtpolitik mit reinspielt also das ist
eben nicht nur um die Sache ging sondern
das ist auch um die Macht Arithmetik in
der Ampel ging ja also war eine
Regierungskrise der Koalition ist es
jetzt gelungen die einmal die
Reset-Taste zu drücken also einmal so
auf Null zu stellen das war ja fast noch
mal wie bei der Vorstellung des
Koalitionsvertrags dass man sich
hingestellt hat gesagt hat Aufbruch
Paradigmenwechsel und diese Dinge alles
was wir schon gehört haben und worauf
wir auch seit anderthalb Jahren warten
und jetzt ist eben die Frage wie hält
das ich vermute dass ich das System
recht schnell wieder aufhängen wird da
mir die erste These und hören unbedingt
den zweiten geschätzten Kollegen am
Tisch Theo call Leiter des
Hauptstadtstudios hier im ZDF TOS hat
verschiedene Erzählungen gegeben die
eine geht so dass man 100 Stunden
zusammengesetzt hat gesessen hat an der
Spitze also der Bundeskanzler mit dem
Finanzminister und dem Vizekanzler im
Vorfeld und ein Papier erarbeitet hat wo
man sich dann fragen würde worüber war
dann eigentlich so lange zu handeln und
zu verhandeln und eine andere These
unterstellt dass man dieses Papier
offensichtlich nicht von allen Seiten
geschätzt hat was weiß Tool also das
wahrscheinlichste ist das beides stimmt
das nämlich die
schwierige und lange Vorbereitung ein
Spiegelbild dessen ist was in der
Gesellschaft ist auch in der Ampel Frau
lange hat das ja fand ich im Nachhinein
so beschrieben und das schien mir
schlüssig
sieht das nämlich die Ampel zu teilen
auch die gesellschaftliche Spannweite
dessen beschreibt und als Problem in
sich trägt was wir als Gesellschaft
austrägt in gewisser Weise
dann ist man im Grunde schon bei der
schwangerschaftsanalogie die ja auch ein
bisschen länger dauert
das soll es aber gar nicht entschuldigen
und dann kann es ja durchaus sein dass
innerhalb der Parteien und innerhalb der
verhandlungsgruppen im Kanzleramt dann
auch noch mal Diskussionen entstanden
sein könnten die dazu geführt haben dass
der Abend dann so lang war wir wurde und
ja nicht nur einer in diesem Hause ist
nur Platz für die Wahrheit wir fangen
mal an mit nuripur einem der drei
Parteivorsitzenden der Ampel die wir
heute hier am Tisch haben wie
ordnen Sie Robert habe ich ein der sich
letzte Woche ja oder von 9 Tagen
exakterweise noch beschwert hat dass er
eigentlich allein gegen zwei
Koalitionspartner kämpf und für den
Klimaschutz kämpft und sich ehrlich
gesagt gestern bei Marietta Slomka im
heute journal nicht ganz anders anhörte
sondern wieder sagte dass wenigstens
einer einen halben Schritt auf den
anderen zugegangen sei ist auch in ihren
Augen jetzt alles schön kann ja nicht es
ist richtig dass wir uns aufeinander zu
bewegt haben das haben wir gemacht das
hat die FDP gemacht das hat die SPD
gemacht und der das war auch nötig sonst
wenn man nicht zum Ergebnis gekommen und
wir haben sehr lange miteinander
gesessen und sehr lange miteinander
gerungen und haben Blockaden aufgelöst
und am Ende Lösung geliefert und das ist
das was die Leute von uns sehen wollen
und ähm das war ein mühsamer Weg und den
sehen wir gegangen sie sagen nicht dass
nur die Grünen sich bewegt haben sie
sagen also Ricarda lang ist so zu
zitieren dass sie ehrlicherweise nicht
glücklich ist mit dem was beim
Klimaschutz rumgekommen ist und wir
können Robert habe gleich noch mal hören
der sagte wenigstens einer sollte ja
eineinhalb auf den anderen zugegangen
ich empfinde das nicht als Widerspruch
weder zu dem was ich gesagt habe noch
zum zum Geister des Kompromisses den wir
dann miteinander auch tatsächlich
erarbeitet haben wir haben uns alle
bewegt beim Thema Klimaschutz schaue mir
da drauf stellen fest dass wir Schritte
nach vorne machen aber dass das nicht
ausreichend ist um die Klimaziele zu
erreichen des bestreitet auch niemanden
und es werden auch das ist aber auch
weitere Diskussionen folgen aber wir
haben
Beschleunigung hinbekommen bei Bahn bei
Brücken bei Trassen bei bestimmten
Straßen und deren Ausbau in diesem Land
auch Autobahnen
beispielsweise bewegt haben aber die
also wir haben zum Beispiel beim Thema
Öl im Gasheizungen haben sich die
anderen bewegt und äh da sind wir jetzt
auf einen guten Weg dass wir miteinander
Zusammenkommen der die Gesetze werden
jetzt erst noch überarbeitet bzw
bearbeitet werden müssen die nächsten
Wochen aber wir haben für vieles eine
Timeline jetzt miteinander
gemerkt gegen eine Augen glaube von
Christian Lindner hoch dazu werden wir
auch noch kommen an sie eine erste
atmosphärische Frage warum hat es in
ihren Augen so lange gedauert und
war also warum oder ja warum war ihre
Freude so grenzenlos weil das durfte man
spüren dass sie das Gefühl hatten sie
sind mit dem Ergebnis dieser drei Tage
ausgesprochen zufrieden alle drei
Koalitionspartner können mit dem
Ergebnis zufrieden sein und was noch
viel wichtiger ist das Ergebnis ist gut
für unser Land niemanden kann doch
überraschen dass es auch harte Gespräche
gibt es geht ja auch um viel und ich
kann absolut nachvollziehen das Bündnis
90 die Grünen sagen wir hätten uns noch
mehr beim Klimaschutz gewünscht das ja
eines der wesentlichen und Kernthemen
der Grünen aber ich sage aus meiner
Perspektive vieles von dem was grüne
beim Klimaschutz für fortschrittlich
halten davon glaube ich dass es
technologisch nicht möglich ist oder
dass es wirtschaftlich nicht tragfähig
ist oder dass es sozial nicht
verantwortbar ist und so muss eben
gerungen werden zwischen dem
akzeptierten Ziel des Klimaschutzes dass
ich auch verfolgen will und dann eben
auch Alternativen Vorschlägen das mit
anderen Technologien zu machen oder auch
andere Abwägungen zu treffen neben
Klimaschutz etwa auch die soziale
Sensibilität und hier ist schon von
Herrn zurecht unterstrichen worden dass
wir als Ampelkoalition mit zwei eher
linken Parteien und der FDP als Partei
der Mitte auch gesellschaftliche
Konfliktlinien miteinander besprechen
aber eben auch lösen bei meinem
Geschmack könnte es beim nächsten mal
ein bisschen kürzer sein könnte ein
bisschen schneller sein aber am Ende
zählt das Ergebnis wer wird in drei
Jahren darüber nachdenken dass das 31
Stunden gedauert hat wenn wir mehr
erneuerbare Energien mehr Schiene
Lückenschlüsse bzw Engpässe bei
Autobahnen beseitigt in Naturschutz
Fortschritte gemacht haben dann zählt
doch das nicht dann zählt das nicht und
trotzdem ist es jetzt natürlich
interessant und sie werden die nächste
Frage entschuldigen es wird erzählt
Christian Lindner und das ist auch zu
lesen dass sie mit diesem erarbeiteten
Papier von Olaf Scholz dem Vizekanzler
Robert Habeck und dem Finanzminister
also sie höchst selbst so einverstanden
waren dass sie sich am Sonntag
zurücklehnten und sagten ich bin mit
diesem Papier vollständig einverstanden
warum musste dann eigentlich noch so
lange behandelt werden ganz so war es
nicht richtig ist dass der Bundeskanzler
der Wirtschaftsminister und ich im
Vorfeld intensiv gearbeitet haben und
das dann aus diesen Gesprächen herr
Scholz eine Tischvorlage gemacht hat
einen Beschlussvorschlag und ich habe da
nicht gesagt ich bin vollständig
zufrieden sondern ich habe ausgeführt
die Kollegen waren dabei im Sinne einer
gesamteinigung
könnten wir die FDP die Kompromisse die
hier aufgezeigt sind mittragen dann
werden wir schneller fertig gewesen
allerdings muss ich dir Ehrlichkeit
halber auch einräumen mit dem
Endergebnis nach 31 Stunden bin ich auf
sich der FDP zufriedener als mit dem was
wir Sonntagabend hätten akzeptieren
können das ist aber ein ziemliches Ding
mit weil dann sagen sie aus ihrer Sicht
wäre es sogar gut gewesen dass
anzunehmen weil das was dann noch raus
verhandelt wurde für Sie
besser ist oder schlechter ist besser
ist besser ja also ich bin nach den 31
Stunden zufriedener mit dem Ergebnis als
ich es am Sonntagabend gewesen wäre okay
hat es die also ich muss sie jetzt nicht
fragen ob es diese Situation gegeben hat
aber man hätte sich einen Großteil
dieser drei Tage sparen können oder
worüber ist dann eigentlich noch
verhandelt worden naja es ist über das
Papier verhandelt worden und über die
Konfliktpunkte die ja da sind und das
war muss eigentlich drumherum reden das
waren den Wochen vorher offensichtlich
dass es Konflikte gibt die gelöst werden
müssen in der Regierung zwischen den
Parteien zwischen den Fraktion
und wissen Sie ich habe auch immer
gesagt
keine
nachtaktiv dass Mama Zurückweisung
dazu sagen dieses ganze dieses ganze
vermessen ja was ich jetzt seit dem Ende
des Koalitionsausschusses erlebe wer hat
gewonnen wer hat verloren wer also das
waren ja produktive Diskussion aber es
war auch richtig nicht dass wir genau
diese Diskussion führen wie schaffen wir
das das berechtigte Ziel des
Klimaschutzes dass wir alle haben ich
erlebe jetzt seit Tagen eine
Auseinandersetzung über die Frage ob wir
Klimaschutz aufgegeben haben weil wir
das Klimaschutzgesetz geändert haben was
aber schlichtweg falsch ist weil das
schon im Koalitionsvertrag angelegt war
dass wir diese Änderung machen ich auch
die feste Überzeugung habe dass vieles
jetzt noch effizienter und
ambitionierter laufen kann und die
eigentlichen Ziele die Minderungsziele
ja nicht aufgegeben werden aber wie
schaffen wir das Klimaschutz
hinzukriegen und gleichzeitig an der
ökonomischen Stärke zu arbeiten
Infrastruktur auszubauen wie kriegen wir
das in Planungs und
Genehmigungsverfahren zu beschleunigen
wir kriegen wir das hin beim Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren noch schneller zu werden so
über diese Konflikte haben wir alle
diskutiert und am Ende finde ich haben
wir wirklich Lösung gefunden die das
Land in den nächsten 10 20 Jahren nach
vorne bringen werden das ist das
Hauptanliegen gewesen und ich habe kein
Problem wenn wir drei Tage darüber
diskutieren am Ende aber für die
nächsten 20 Jahre das Land verändert
reklamiert für sich in eva klappbeck ist
gleich dran Robert Hagenbeck reklamiert
für sich und die Grünen die
Arbeitsfähigkeit dieser Regierung
ermöglicht zu haben weil er sich am
meisten bewegt hat sprich am meisten
Federn gelassen hat wir gehen da gleich
ins Detail das sehen sie nicht sie sehen
nicht das haben sich bewegt alle waren
konstruktiv und diese Regierung besteht
aus drei unterschiedlichen Parteien wir
sind in einer herausfordernden Situation
für das Land das war schon so als wir
den Koalitionsvertrag geschlossen haben
das ist durch den Krieg noch mal
dringlicher geworden dass wir wirklich
große Schritte nach vorne brauchen dass
wir große Veränderungen in diesem Land
brauchen und da bewegen sich alle drei
also das ist eine völliger Quatsch das
eine Seite sich dann mehr bewegt hat als
die andere es ist ein guter Kompromiss
und der ist für alle drei positiv und
sind dankbar für die politische
Einordnung welche Rolle diesmal der
Bundeskanzler gespielt hat Eva gerade
weg normalerweise unterstellte man ihm
ja dass er relativ lange zuschaute wenn
grüne und die FDP sich streiten diesmal
sagt man es ist mehr zu Lasten der
Grünen gegangen was da jetzt ein
Einigung auf dem Tisch liegt auch wenn
Herr kling mal das die Einteilung in
Gewinner und Verlierer nicht so mag aus
meiner Sicht ist der Kanzler der
heimliche Gewinner dieser dieses
Streitgesprächs oder dieser dieser
großen Koalitionsausschuss
weil die ganze Zeit eben Grüne und FDP
gegeneinander gelaufen sind mit dem was
sie wollten auch in Interviews vorher
also Sie haben ja gerade das Habeck
Interview vorher zitiert die SPD hat
sich da nicht in den Wind gestellt und
gesagt was sie eigentlich möchte sie
geht da taktisch inzwischen sehr stark
in die Richtung wie das auch Merkel und
die CDU 16 Jahre lang gemacht haben und
für den Kanzler ist es natürlich
durchaus praktisch dass
Herr harberg und Herr Lindner wie Hund
und Katze aufeinander reagieren also
einander die gegenseitig die Signale
nicht verstehen bzw mit deuten und immer
das Signal des anderen dem einen
missfällt und dadurch ist der Kanzler in
der komfortabelsten Situation dass er
sagt die FDP ist der kleinere der
schwächere Teil in dieser Koalition und
deshalb tue ich mehr für die FDP in der
Kompromissfindung und was ich gehört
habe hat er ja durchaus Pendel
Diplomatie gegeben dass man immer dass
der Kanzler da auch zu beiden Seiten
hingegangen ist und für ihn den Vorteil
dass er auch sein eigene SPD bei der
Stange halten kann weil er dann der SPD
sagen kann so ich muss hier den
Kompromiss mit der FDP machen deshalb
können wir uns auf der ganzer Linie
nicht durchsetzen und die Grünen werden
zugleich natürlich geschwächt dadurch
und die Grünen sind ja auch der größte
Konkurrent für die SPD also es ist
praktisch für den Kanzler wenn so läuft
das müssen sie auch noch mal erklären
warum sind die Grünen der größere
Konkurrenz für die SPD wenn wir auf die
nächste Bundestagswahl schauen dann
werden die Grünen sicherlichen
Kanzlerkandidaten Kanzlerkandidatin
aufstellen die FDP wird das nicht tun
also sind die Grünen die größere
Konkurrenz sind SPD und Grüne zwei
Parteien im linken Lager da ist mehr
Wähler austauschen insofern stimmt aber
ansonsten bitte mit einem Respekt
aufzunehmen wenn ich sage das ist eine
kreative Ferndiagnose ist denn die
Gespräche waren sehr sachlich und wenn
ich auch das sagen darf mit einem
Respekt die Gesprächsführung jetzt krank
ein bisschen daran dass wir sehr
oberflächlich auf Gewinner und Verlierer
und Machtpolitik schauen und ich bin mir
sicher ich bin mir sicher wenn wir in
die Sachthemen jetzt einsteigen etwa
beim Naturschutz oder bei
planungsungenehmigungsverfahren oder
beim Klimaschutz dann wird sehr schnell
deutlich werden das ist ein ausgewogenes
Ergebnis gut das werden wir versuchen
ich kann noch mal zusammenfassen dass es
ja aber eine völlig berechtigte Frage
ist ob die Bürger dieses Landes theokol
weiter mit einem gewissen Misstrauen
aufziehen Zusammenhalt dieser Koalition
schauen also ob von von 9 Tagen diese
Situation jetzt wirklich ausgeräumt ist
und die meisten Dinge
besprochen sind oder ob das eigentlich
munter weitergeht weil man sich sowohl
über die Finanzen als auch über andere
inhaltliche Fragen Stichwort die Kinder
wohnsicherung eben noch nicht
verständigt hat also ich bin sicher dass
die dass die nächsten Umfragen werden
zeigen dass die Zufriedenheit mit dem
Zusammenhalt der Koalition
dramatisch abnimmt das ist absehbar aber
das ist glaube ich zeitrangig also die
die inhaltliche Frage wie die Koalition
mit den großen Fragen umgeht das ist
glaube ich das entscheidende und da
sehen wir ja interessanterweise Herr
Lindner hat ja gesagt also es gibt im
Grunde zwei linke Parteien und untern
die FDP wir hatten ja jetzt eine andere
Konstellation
was ja eigentlich politisch erstmal
überraschend ist dass die SPD und die
FDP näher waren inhaltlich sie schütteln
den Kopf aber wenn man sich die
Ergebnisse anschauen moderiert oder er
hat sich an die Seite der FDP
geschmissen beide
erzählen
aber wenn sie sich die Inhalte wirklich
nein der lassen uns wirklich einsteigen
das ja also wir waren dabei das ist ja
unser kleiner Vorteil hier ausnahmsweise
bei uns dreien ist das wäre dabei war
und ich bitte z.B das will ich nur sagen
wenn zum Beispiel in der Sache ist ob
die SPD dafür ist das Autobahn
Teilprojekte ausgebaut werden und
Engpässe beseitigt werden nicht
akzeptiere und verstehe dass es nicht
das Hauptanliegen der grün ist aber wir
sind dafür die FDP sind dafür aber genau
aber es ist doch kein machtpolitisches
randschmeißen
Koalition stellen in diesem 16-seitigen
Papier anders gegeben dass da vielleicht
auch mal grün und FDP beieinander waren
und man mit der SPD das ist völlig okay
aber ich erlebe ich erlebe das in dieser
Berliner politikwelt ist dann am Ende
gar nicht mehr um die Sachfragen geht
sondern nur noch eine Minute und ab
jetzt reden wir über Inhalte Dinge und
sagen vor allem der Klimaschutz
war schuld daran dass diese Koalition
sich verkeilt und verkantet hatte wie es
noch sehr freundlich heißt und die
Beschlüsse waren vielleicht können wir
so zusammenfassen nicht für alle
befriedigen
die größten Kröten müssen die Grünen
schlucken bis zu 140 Autobahnabschnitte
sollen jetzt beschleunigt ausgebaut
werden allerdings bei gleichzeitiger
Nutzung der Randflächen für Solar
der Verkehrssektor als CO2 Sorgenkind
bleibt von drastischen Maßnahmen
verschont
werden hier die Klimaziele weiter
verfehlt können Sie mit denen anderer
Ministerien verrechnet werden
die umstrittene wärmewende bleibt in
Neubauten sollen Heizungen ab 1 Januar
2024 möglichst zu 65% mit erneuerbaren
Energien betrieben werden die teuren
wärmepumpen sind aber nicht zwingend
auch andere Technologien können Gas und
Öl ersetzen
mehr Autobahnausbau sektorenziele
aufgeweicht wärmewende eben mit dieser
neuen Technologie also mit der
Erweiterung einer konkreten Möglichkeit
auch Gasheizungen mit Wasserstoff zu
betreiben um eben dieses Klimaziel zu
erreichen war das alternativlos oder
haben sie einfach schlecht verhandelt
werde ich noch mal zurückkommen darf zu
dem vorherigen ich teile das wir gerade
als Koalition mit der Spannbreite in
gesellschaftlichen Debatten auch um
Klimaschutz sehr viel miteinander
diskutieren und auch zu weit streiten
müssen und zu Ergebnissen zu kommen aber
darin liegt auch eine riesengroße Chance
nämlich dass wir die die Debatten am
Ende so führen dass wir das Land
voranbringen und und verschiedene Güte
und Interessen zusammenbringen wir
glauben dass das Papier das Ergebnis was
wir gerade vorliegen haben am Ende nicht
ausreichend ist aber ehrlich gesagt wir
sind nicht die einzigen und ich weiß
dass wir und alle wissen in der
Koalition dass wir in dieser Frage des
klimasch das ist an vielen anderen
Baustellen werden miteinander
diskutieren müssen sie haben gerade
gesagt
neu Ausbau das stimmt ja nicht der die
Ausbau von diesen 144 Teilstücken wir
reden über 34 Stücke 34 Teilstücke von
Autobahnen in den sieben Bundesländern
also teilweise Projekte Teilstücke sind
längst beschlossen und jetzt gilt es
dass die beschleunigt werden wenn die
Bundesländer jeweils finden dass es
sinnvoll ist und das wird jetzt das
nächste laufende der nächsten 12 Monate
miteinander diskutiert und dann werden
wir mal sehen wo wir hinkommen aber
und deshalb sage ich ja dass wir unter
dem Strich nicht finden das alles
perfekt ist in dem Papier aber wir haben
ja am Ende des Papier mitgetragen
gibt's die größte Lücke beim Klimaschutz
das ist glaube ich jetzt Binsenweisheit
wissen dass Deutschland im
Verkehrsbereich 14 immer mehr liefern
muss am Ende des Tages und die
Klimaziele zu erreichen auch wenn sie
verrechnet werden mit den anderen davon
wie gerade beschrieben worden ist so
viel kompensieren können die anderen
Sektoren oft auf der Strecke ja nicht
aber wir haben beispielsweise beim
Bahnausbau jetzt nicht nur eine
Beschleunigung sondern auch die
Finanzierungslücke die es gibt die
nächsten vier Jahren miteinander
beschrieben von 45 Milliarden und haben
jetzt signifikant eine signifikante
Schritte jetzt miteinander unternommen
um um diese Lücke klein und kleiner zu
machen auf die Schiene zu bringen nur
ein Beispiel es gibt noch einige andere
die wir auch vorher gemacht haben vom 49
Euro Ticket bis zum Ausfüllen fossilen
Verbrenner von 2035 in Europa
völlig Recht so wäre es beschreibt sind
viele starke Punkte drin die auch dem
Klimaschutz helfen ist ja ein
gemeinsames Ziel dass wir haben und das
ist schon eine sehr starke Agenda freue
mich auch sehr dass wir bei der Schiene
jetzt sehr viel mehr tun das ist eine
Infrastruktur man schämt sich ja fast
das Kind Charles Morgen mit einem ICE
von Berlin nach Hamburg fährt und hofft
der ist dann mal pünktlich auf der
Strecke ist das meistens aber insgesamt
ist die Bahn nicht in einem guten
Zustand und dass der Volker Wissing
jetzt die Mittel bekommt dass nach vorne
zu bringen ist ja gut aber manches darf
doch gar nicht überraschen dass wir
jetzt das Klimaschutzgesetz das übrigens
mit CDU Stimmen damals sehr
planwirtschaftlich aufgestellt worden
ist dass das jetzt flexibler und
marktwirtschaftlicher wird das ist keine
Überraschung das steht im
Koalitionsvertrag manche Journalistinnen
und mancher Journalist hat nicht daran
geglaubt dass das ernst gemeint ist was
im Koalitionsvertrag steht aber das
haben wir ernst gemeint und genau diese
Aufhebung der starrensektor Ziele stand
bereits im Koalitionsvertrag kann
niemanden überraschen wenn Sie den
Gedanken noch erlauben bei ihrem
Einspieler gerade da wird dann so
bedauernd von ihrem oft Sprecher in den
Beitrag gerade gesagt ja im Verkehr gibt
es jetzt keine drastischen Maßnahmen ich
darf mal fragen will das deutsche Volk
denn eigentlich drastische Maßnahmen im
Verkehr aller Fahrverbote oder
verpflichtende autoquote und dann wird
das ein Einsatz noch man wird in diesem
Beitrag auch so bedauernd gesagt von
Ihrer Redaktion ja das Verbot von
Gasheizung kommt jetzt nicht das wird so
bedauernd in ihrem Beitrag dargestellt
die Grünen konnten sich mit dem Verbot
von Gasheizungen nicht durchsetzen ich
will sie fragen freuener will das
deutsche Volk das eigentlich und deshalb
glaube ich auch wenn einzelne Parteien
mal Federn lassen mussten bei ihren
Maximalforderungen für das Land und für
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger war das ein
Gewinn gut also ich zitiere jetzt nur
den letzten Absatz noch mal sonst kommen
vielleicht auch der Zuschauer ein
bisschen durcheinander die umstrittene
wärmewende bleibt haben wir gesagt in
Neubauten sollen Heizungen ab 1 Januar
24 möglichst zu 65% mit erneuerbaren
Energien betrieben werden die teuren
wärmepumpen sind aber nicht zwingend
auch andere Technologien können Gas und
Öl ersetzen ich glaube jeder dieser
Sätze auch Gas er ist da übrigens mit
drin aber sie stellen zur da als wäre
das ein schlimmes Zugeständnis der
Grünen gewesen ist ungefähr das was das
Gesetz ist glaube dass das im Interesse
der Menschen ist dass das so geregelt
wird
das ganze drei Tage gedauert hat
vielleicht können wir noch mal folgende
Frage stellen ehrlich gesagt weil wir
mit dieser heizungsgeschichte und damit
sind wir mitten in den Inhalten und um
die sollte es uns ja gehen mit der
Diskussion um dieses
gebäudegesetz und die die wärmewende hat
sich das deutsche Volk ja jetzt fünf
Wochen befasst sind Theo call die
Unterstellungen richtig zu sagen die
Grünen empfinden das so dass sie im
Grunde genommen in eine Situation
hineingezwungen wurden auch bei der
wärmewende sich gegen Verbote und
Verbote reden andere Parteien übrigens
auch der FDP zu wären der kann sie hat
gesagt eigentlich sind Öl und
Gasheizungen nie verboten worden und ein
striktes Verbot hat es nie und hätte es
zu keiner Zeit gegeben worden da können
wir auch gleich noch mal zitieren des
FDP-Politiker immer unterstellt haben
Herr Habeck würde verbieten wollen also
was war das für ein Spiel und wo ist ein
kommunikatives und wo ein inhaltliches
Problem ich glaube es würde Sinn machen
auch auf uns als Bürger zu schauen
wir haben ja wir erleben ja
möglicherweise im Moment und da ist der
Stichwort Auto im weitesten Sinne
Autobahnbau wir hatten bei der FDP die
Diskussion um e-vuols wir haben
natürlich klare Mehrheiten in der
Bevölkerung für das Auto wir haben
große Sorge bei einem so tiefen Eingriff
wie einem einer Umstellung der Heizung
kann ich mir das erlauben wie geht das
und so weiter also all diese
Unsicherheiten und das sind natürlich im
Grunde sind da ja Mehrheiten und wenn
wir jetzt und das werden wir glaube ich
erleben dass die Grünen runtergehen und
FDP hochgeht dann darf man glaube ich
zurecht auch ein gewisses politisch
strategisches Element unterstellen dass
die inhaltliche Diskussion auch damit zu
tun hat also sich für das Auto
einzusetzen für die Autobahn für den
Autobahnausbau und so weiter mir hat
auch niemals jemand vorgeworfen ich
würde mich nur aus taktischen Gründen
für das Auto interessieren und mir hat
noch niemals vorgeworfen ich würde die
Leute die Autos wegnehmen wollen und das
tun wir auch nicht es geht ja auch darum
dass die dass die CO2 frei sind bzw
klimaneutral sind und da die die diese
letzten beiden Begriffe haben wir
miteinander verhandelt und und mehr auch
nicht ist ging nicht darum dass man
jetzt autofrei wird aber das haben sie
ja nicht erreicht dass ich mir das war
ja im Vorfeld jeder jeder dement gefragt
hat das aus der Partei der wollte doch
im Grunde die Gegenleistung haben dass
sie gesagt haben okay wir werden
bestimmt ein Autobahnen Ausbau Projekten
zustimmen
Beschleunigung genau wenn der
Verkehrsbereich im Grunde einen Termin
round biete wir haben noch einmal ich
will nicht hinsetzen und
jetzt werden wir ein riesen Party feiern
es ist nicht der Fall ich habe ja gesagt
es ist nicht alles perfekt wie wir es
uns vorgestellt hätten aber ich finde 20
Milliarden zusätzlich die nächsten vier
Jahre für die Bahn ist jetzt kein es ist
nicht nicht
die die Bahn eigentlich braucht wenn Sie
eine saniert werden soll wir sind jetzt
schon wieder ein bisschen hin und her
gesprungen ich versuch's noch mal
zuordnen uns hat Deutschland hat jeden
Bürger hat also fast 80 Millionen
Menschen nee sind ja auch Kinder dabei
also sagen wir vielleicht 60 Millionen
Menschen tatsächlich befasst wie wir
übermorgen in diesem Land heizen werden
da ist interessanter klingt bald zu
fragen welches eigentlich die Position
der SPD und des Bundeskanzlers ist sagen
sie auch hier
technologieoffenheit was übrigens stimmt
dann von Anfang an im Koalitionsvertrag
schließen sie sich Frau geibels an die
noch mit März gesagt hat eine CO2
bessere Technologie werden wir niemals
und auf keinen Fall
verbieten per Gesetz oder sagen Sie da
ist tatsächlich irgendwie von den Grünen
etwas anderes gefordert worden und wir
sind uns dann nicht einig gewesen und es
war gut dass wir uns verständigt haben
darauf dass jetzt eine
Gasheizung mit Biomethan betrieben
werden kann also wir haben im
Koalitionsvertrag danach noch mal im
Koalitionsausschuss vor knapp einem Jahr
festgelegt dass wir wollen das ab 24
65%
Anteil erneuerbare möglichst in allen
neu verbauten Heizanlagen drin sein soll
und das gilt das wird jetzt umgesetzt
aber wir hatten und das war das Problem
wir hatten die letzten Wochen eine
kommunikative Lage wo der Eindruck
entstanden ist bei vielen Bürgerinnen
und Bürger ich hätte selbst in vielen
Bürger Gesprächen erlebt da steht der
Robert habe
Januar 2024 persönlich vor der Tür und
reißt die ganze Gasheizung aus
da sind wir reingekommen und das zeigt
und ich stimme zu wie groß die Angst
dann auch vor Klimaschutz sein kann weil
das Ziel bleibt ja richtig dass wir auf
diese 65 Prozent gehen wenn jetzt neue
Heizanlagen verbaut würden das Ziel
bleibt doch richtig wenn alte
Heizanlagen kaputt sind und die müssen
getauscht werden so und deswegen war für
uns als SPD wichtig
aber deswegen war für uns wichtig und da
steht ja klar in diesem Papier drin dass
wir diesen Weg gehen wollen mit den 65%
natürlich technologieoffen dass das ist
ja die Erfüllung auch der 65%, aber klar
muss eben sein die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger können sich darauf verlassen dass
wir niemanden im Stich lassen dass wir
Förderprogramme auf den Weg bringen
werden und dass wir dafür sorgen dass
auch soziale Härten abgefedert werden
das ist das Klimaschutz mit Vernunft
nochmal festgeschrieben fragen wir noch
mal den Grünen und nämlich Herr norrisur
sagen die Grünen dass es völlig in
Ordnung ist wenn jetzt in eine gasheit
Sitzung
Biomethan fließt und dann ist es im
Grunde genommen auch da eine wärmewende
eingelöst also wir reden über die
technologieoffenheit und über das
ermöglichen eine gasinfrastruktur die
gestern ja noch Brückentechnologie waren
jetzt weiter zu erlauben und zu
ermöglichen in Deutschland das erlauben
ja und es ermöglichen auch wir werden ja
eine Bundesregierung wird im Aprilia
jetzt ähnlichen Gesetzesentwurf vorlegen
wir haben ja bisher ein
Referentenentwurf fünf Wochen lang alle
miteinander diskutiert was ungewöhnlich
ist und wir wollen bis zum Sommer auch
dieses Gesetzesverfahren abschließen so
dass auch schnellstmöglich auch die
Leute ihre Vorbereitung treffen können
für Neubau wir reden ausschließlich über
Neubau und dabei wird es auch Biomethan
Möglichkeiten geben und unter bestimmten
Regeln natürlich auch Wasserstoff die
Frage der Verfügbarkeit stellt sich
allerdings natürlich bei beiden und am
Ende des Tages ist unsere Überzeugung
nach Wärmepumpe
deutlich einfacher aber das wird sich
weisen
meine es gibt ja war ihnen war Herr
Lindner Entschuldigung war
offensichtlich genau diese Möglichkeit
die
heizungstechnologie eben im wahrsten
Sinne des Wortes zu öffnen so wichtig
dass sie es extra erwähnten auf dieser
Pressekonferenz vor zwei Tagen
außerdem sollen fossile Heizungen
weiterhin zugelassen werden die
Wasserstoff oder grüne Gase ready sind
sofern es eine entsprechende Planung für
das Gasnetz gibt
so
ganz einfache Frage wann wird es diese
Technologie geben wann wird es eine
wasserstofffähige Gasheizung geben was
gibt es jetzt schon am Markt aber ich
muss ganz kurz diese kleine Passage
erläutern die sie nur ausschnittsweise
jetzt zitieren konnten wir haben uns im
Koalitionsausschuss ganz am Ende darauf
verständigt dass ich genau die Passage
die ich dort vorgelesen habe ich habe
sonst frei gesprochen dass ich diese
Passage vorlesen kann um zu beschreiben
was heißt technologieoffen es geht noch
ein bisschen weiter als jetzt zeigen
konnten weil im Papier steht
technologieoffen aber das sind sehr
abstrakter Begriff und es gibt aber
offensichtlich auch verschiedene
verwandt worden die einen meinten ist
technisch und die anderen
auch technisch und die Frage geht ja
darum 65% erneuerbare Energie was
bedeutet das was trägt dazu bei
beispielsweise
Holzpellets leisten
65 Prozent erneuerbarer Energie und es
gibt noch was zweites haben wir jetzt
nicht hier heute diskutiert natürlich
war im politischen Raum so sage ich das
mal neutral war ein politischen Raum
auch die Vorstellung man könnte eine
Verpflichtung beschließen das ab einem
bestimmten Jahr oder nach einer
bestimmten Nutzungszeit verpflichtend
auch eine funktionierende Gasheizung
ausgetauscht werden muss das wurde im
politischen Raum diskutiert ich sage das
mal so nebulös ich sage das so nebulös
und es ist glaube ich wichtig dass diese
Idee einer
verpflichtenden Austausch über das was
wir jetzt bereits im Gesetz haben es
gibt schon jetzt bestimmte gesetzliche
Regelungen dass darüber hinaus eine
Verschärfung unterbleibt denn man muss
doch die Lebenssachverhalte vor Augen
haben das sind doch mitunter ältere
Menschen die haben sie ihr ganzes Leben
lang krummgelegt und leben und leben
jetzt leben jetzt im Ruhestand in ihrem
Einfamilienhaus mit einer Heizung von
1986 und haben Angst dass im Jahr 2027
der Staat kommt und sagt diese Heizung
musst du ausbauen und dann geht es bei
denen nicht um die Heizung sondern eine
Wärmepumpe macht ja zum Beispiel nur
Sinn wenn du auch das Haus energetisch
sanierst und
dämmstlich mit 100.000 mit 100.000 Euro
oder oder unter Druck und das müssen wir
verhindern und da geht es eben nicht nur
über Lars klingen weil um den sozialen
Ausgleich also Subventionen die der
Steuerzahler finanziert sondern auch
dass wir das ambitionsniveau der
wärmewende an das Anpassen was sozial
akzeptiert und volkswirtschaftlich
vernünftig ist wenn wir gleich fragen
was ist diese Geschwindigkeit und was
kann man den Menschen zumuten hier
fragen wir erstmal nach dem politischen
Raum haben sie eine Erklärung wer
gemeint ist wenn Christian Lindner sagt
eben politischen Raum ist eine
Verpflichtung diskutiert worden ist ja
natürlich haben eine Vorstellung wieder
dabei
Vergangenheit erstens das und zweitens
gab es 2019 beispielsweise ja auch ein
Beschluss der großen Koalition das
Gasheizung
es geht nur um Vergleichbarkeit von von
Gesetzgebung
das kommt für den für diejenigen der in
Ölheizung hat kommt genauso aus aber
entscheidend ist dass wir jetzt
Vorankommen in der Gesetzgebung
entscheidend ist dass wir tatsächlich
auch Gelder bereitstellen für diejenigen
die es brauchen damit wir auch das
ermöglichen dass wir so schnell wie
möglich Vorankommen 40% der Emissionen
in diesem Land kommen aus dem
Gebäudebereich und da müssen wir besser
werden wenn wir vorankommen wollen
richtig also das wir etwas tun müssen
ist den Leuten bewusst jetzt waren wir
bei der Frage nach der Geschwindigkeit
und der Zumutbarkeit Robert Habeck hat
wiederum gestern in dem Interview gesagt
dass wir wahrscheinlich mit 80 Millionen
Deutschen in diesem Land ihre private
Situation verhandeln müssen denn es geht
in einen sehr privaten Bereich wenn wir
über den Wohnraum über die Heizung und
über das Auto reden um Klimaschutz zu
ermöglichen in diesem Land schließt sich
der Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz Herr
klingbei schließt sich die SPD an was
Christian Lindner sagt wir dürfen die
Menschen nicht überfordern und erst
recht nicht in dieser Krisensituation in
der Deutschland sich jetzt befindet
das ist ja das Signal auch von Sonntag
Montag Dienstag gewesen dass wir den
Klimaschutz voranbringen aber das wird
die Menschen mitnehmen auf diesem Weg
und das betrifft ja alles ich meine das
betrifft auch wenn sie ins Papier
reingucken wie schaffen wir den Umstieg
in der Mobilität durch den Ausbau der
Lage Infrastruktur sehr schön aber es
wird nur so funktionieren weil es kann
am Ende nicht sein dass man hier in
Berlin diskutiert dass man jetzt auf die
S-Bahn Lastenräder sonst was umsteigt
und im ländlichen Raum haben die
Menschen genau zwei Möglichkeiten
entweder sie steigen ins Auto oder Sie
bleiben zu Hause es wird nicht
funktionieren wir müssen die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger mitnehmen deswegen klares
Signal den ÖPNV auszubauen klares Signal
die Bahn auszubauen Bahntickets
zugänglich zu machen für die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger und bei der heizungsfrage
auch da diese Unsicherheit die da war
die letzten Tage die gewachsen ist alle
wollen den Klimaschutz aber fragen sich
natürlich was bedeutet das für mich
privat kann ich mir das leisten kann ich
da mir das erlauben was ist die
Konsequenz wenn über Heizung geredet
wird im politischen Berlin so da haben
wir klar gesagt wir lassen jemanden im
Stich und das wird jetzt im
Gesetzgebungsverfahren auch mit der
Frage Fördermöglichkeiten und alles
geklärt aber wir müssen diesen Weg gehen
sie müssen den Weg gehen sie haben die
Kritik zur Kenntnis genommen also nicht
nur von den entsprechenden
Organisationen Greenpeace NABU und so
das meldet sich die Grüne Jugend ist
meldet sich auch Andreas Jungen von der
CDU es melden sich Kollegen aus dem
Bundestag die sagen das ist kein Klima
Kanzler mehr sondern ein
Bundesverkehrsminister
dieses verkehrskanzler haben übrigens
das witzigste gerade gesagt dass die das
die CDU sich so an die Grünen also die
sonst immer in der Opposition die
marktwirtschaftliche Partei sein will
einer aus Baden-Württemberg der lebt da
Schwarz-Grün und insofern haben so viel
gescholtene große Koalition hat das
damals hingekriegt im Klimaschutz die
Sektoren Grenzen zu verankern und die
waren sehr sinnvoll weil sie jeden
Sektor dazu gezwungen haben die
Einsparungen zu erbringen und die sind
jetzt weg die sind jetzt weg und damit
bestätige Gefahr dass wirklich alle
Ziele gerissen werden weil der eine
verlässt sich auf den anderen und das
sorgt dann einfach dafür dass am Ende
das Klimaziel so nicht erreichen
marktwirtschaftliches Instrument ist
besser als ein planwirtschaftliches und
ich bleibe dabei aber bei einem Respekt
wir dürfen ja unterschiedliche
Bewertungen haben das Klimaschutzgesetz
der großen Koalition war eben nicht gut
das war Plan wissenschaftlich
die Menschen das ist für die Menschen
nicht gut weil wir müssen doch alles mit
wirtschaftlicher Vernunft machen und das
Ziel muss doch sein mit jedem
eingesetztem Euro Steuergeld so viel CO2
Einsparung wie möglich und es ist
vielleicht denkbar im Bereich Energie
und Industrie pro eingesetztem Euro mehr
Klimaschutz
Mobilität oder Gebäude natürlich
Verantwortlichkeiten auf und es ist
etwas was die
Lebensmittel ein bisschen zurücklegen
hier ist noch mal meine Frage die
Gesamtverantwortung der Bundesregierung
für die Einhaltung der Klimaschutzziele
unangetastet bleibt und wenn die Kinder
davon gesagt hat dreimal unterstreichen
diese Änderung diese Änderung des
klimaschutzgesetzes haben wir im
Koalitionsvertrag festgelegt ich habe
damals als einer Stelle haben
Schrei erlebt damals alle haben gesagt
dieser Koalitionsvertrag steht der
Klimaschutz okay deswegen und weil sie
gerade den Kollegen von der CDU hätte
die anderen
vorlegen ist doch klar
derjenige was wir im Bereich der
Baden-Württemberg Entschuldigung was wir
im Bereich der erneuerbaren Energien und
das Ausbaus an den Tag legen durch
mehrere Gesetze die Robert habe ich
jetzt schon im ersten Jahr der Regierung
gemacht hat aber jetzt auch noch mal
durch die Planungs- und
genehmigungsbeschleunigung die da an
diesem Papier mit drin steht das wird
das Land verändern das wird dafür sorgen
dass wir mehr Klimaschutz endlich auf
die Reihe kriegen in diesem Land weil es
nicht mehr ich kenne Beispiele der laut
die Windkraftanlage 18 Jahre bis die
realisiert wird durch die Kommentar 23
große Hälfte das zu schaffen und das
bringt den Klimaschutz mehr voran als
vieles was in den letzten Jahrzehnten
Person sie haben jetzt ihren beiden
Koalitionspartnern können sie haben
total recht wir müssen da endlich mit
einem eher NIV Studierenden zwar
geschriebenen Sektor Ziel aber
verrechenbaren sektorziell unterwegs
sein damit sich viel schneller was
bewegt erstens ist es so dass am Ende am
Anfang ja
bisher so war dass wir hier was pro
Sektor geschaut haben was für in den
letzten Jahren und zurzeit gibt es
nach vorne
Fortschritt weil die Zahlen der letzten
zwei Jahre sind trügerisch weil
beispielsweise durch die Pandemie die
Industrie einfach gefahren ist und das
einfach nicht wirklich wieder viel
ausgesagt hat deshalb schauen wir nach
vorne ersten zweitens ist es ja auch
dann am Ende weil die Klimaziele ja klar
sind und klar bleiben und die Sektor
Ziele klar sind und klar bleiben auch
transparent und deutlich welche Sektoren
wie viel leisten hätten müssen um die
Klimaziele zu erreichen die Sektor Ziele
sind Transparenz steht auch da drin das
haben auch miteinander vereinbaren dann
wird mehrjährig in dem Fall zweijährig
dann jeweils geschaut wo gibt's denn die
meisten Lücken und derjenige dann muss
erstmal derjenige der für den Bereich
zuständig ist dann Vorschläge machen wie
wir dann vorankommen und die
Bundesregierung muss sich dann damit
beschäftigen
ich bleibt am Ende das kann man bis zum
Ende aller Tage diskutieren am Ende des
Tages haben wir die fünf Jahre Schritte
30 35 40 45 wo man jeweils schauen muss
um 45 müssen wir bei Null sein Null
Emission und am Ende des Tages wird es
so sein dass wir in zwei Jahren schauen
und wenn man feststellt dass der
Verkehrssektor weiterhin 14 Mal zu wenig
liefert dann schaut man sich an ob die
anderen das kompensieren können und die
Antwort ist physikalisch nein
wir am Ende des Tages das Gesamtziel
miteinander erreichen aber das wir
gerade im Verkehrsbereich weit mehr
brauchen das ergibt sich aus genau ich
will noch mal so sagen warum die Grünen
seinerzeit bei den
Koalitionsverhandlungen überhaupt
zugestimmt haben das war eine Forderung
der FDP nicht von SPD hat in der großen
Koalition anderes gemacht es war auch
kein Anliegen der Grünen zwar eins von
uns wir haben gesagt wir brauchen
marktwirtschaftliche Instrumente
Klimaschutz soll unsere Wirtschaftskraft
stärken durch Technologie soll aber
nicht Wirtschaftskraft Kosten deshalb
lasst es uns marktwirtschaftlicher
machen dann haben die Kollegen der
Grünen gesagt wir sind bereit euch
zuzustimmen dafür wollen wir aber den
Ausstieg aus der Kohle auf das Jahr 2030
vorziehen das gehört ja zusammen ist
eben gar nicht dargestellt worden das
war ja ein Paket die Veränderung beim
Klimaschutzgesetz und idealerweise 2013
Verzicht auf die Kohle und das wollen
wir auch sofort setzen jetzt durch den
Ukraine Krieg hat sich die Lage
verändert im Westdeutschland jetzt haben
wir noch mehr Kohle im Netz und deshalb
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen dass immer
so auf Volker Wissing geschaut wird und
den Verkehrssektor muss zum einmal sagen
es ist nicht Volker Wissing der die
Klimaziele im Verkehr nicht erreicht es
sind die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
nicht erreichen weil die Menschen eben
Ziel sein wollen und ich finde man muss
dann eben anerkennen im Verkehr haben
wir ein Problem aber man kann nicht
gleichzeitig auf drei klimaneutrale
Kernkraftwerke vorzeitig verzichten und
andererseits sagen dass wir da jetzt
Braunkohle einsetzen müssen das ist
Schuld der Autofahrerin und Autofahrer
und von Volker Wissing das ist auch
jetzt nicht sachgerecht so und jetzt
wollen wir nicht schon wieder eine
atom-diskussion führen weil das hatten
wir schon ich kehre zurück zu der Frage
wird genug eigentlich wollte ich das von
Herrn Klingbeil Wissen wird Olaf Scholz
weiter eine Fortschritt und
klimakkoalition Anführerin
glauben Sie dass die Menschen ihnen das
noch glauben wir arbeiten kollegial und
und gut miteinander zusammen
ehrlich gesagt wir werden dieses Land
nicht voranbringen wenn Digitalisierung
der FDP ist
also soziale gerechtigkeitssache der SPD
ohne Ökologie Sache der Grünen von
vorgestern und das müssen wir zusammen
aufbrechen dass da zuweilen die Rezepte
nicht auf dem ersten Blick
zusammenpassen ist so aber das hat sitzt
man ja auch dann 30 Stunden zusammen und
ist zuweilen dann auch
Currywurst viel zu lange aber wir suchen
ja sogar jetzt am Donnerstag wieder die
Nähe sie suchen aber sowas von die Nähe
als würden sie uns zertrennlich sein wir
müssen unbedingt noch über das gerade
weggeschobene Thema des sozialen
Ausgleichs reden also wir kehren ganz
kurz noch mal zu der heizungsfrage
zurück weil da haben es wahrscheinlich
alle am besten verstanden und auch in
Teilen durchlebt oder durch fürchtet ist
Frage wieder an die beiden Journalisten
Kollegen ist das Versprechen von Robert
Habeck eigentlich einzulösen dass am
Ende Menschen mit mittleren und kleinem
Einkommen den Unterschied den
finanziellen Unterschied zwischen einer
Wärmepumpe Neubau und einer normalen
Gasheizung ausgeglichen bekommen um
ehrlich zu sein ich glaube wir stehen
erst am Anfang eher dramatischen
Diskussionen die wir haben werden ich
meine wir haben geringes
Wirtschaftswachstum der Finanzminister
hat vorgerechnet dass wir wie viel 40
Milliarden Schulden dieses Jahr haben
statt vier Milliarden wir müssen das
zwei Prozent Ziel bei der Verteidigung
erreichen wir müssen in Digitalisierung
investieren also wir haben gigantische
nachhol Finanzierungen die auf uns
zukommen und das bei einem Haushalt der
vielleicht inflationsbedingt wächst aber
ansonsten nicht wirklich also ich glaube
dass wir das eh vor einer ganz großen
Diskussion noch stehen als Land was
können wir noch zahlen wo müssen wir
Abstriche machen was wir noch nie haben
eigentlich in unserer Entwicklung wie
das gar nicht von Wohlstandsverlust
reden aber wo Dinge die wir lieb
gewonnen haben in der Förderung in dem
Angebot des Staates wo wir plötzlich
eine ganz neue Diskussion bekommen
werden ich bin mal gespannt
das ist in diesen drei Tagen nicht
besprochen worden die Finanzen sind
ausgeklammert worden oder vor die
Klammer gepackt worden da gibt es
verschiedene Formulierungen auf jeden
Fall wurde über die Finanzierungsfrage
Frau Quadbeck überhaupt nicht gesprochen
ist es nicht ein Riesenproblem sie
inhaltlich auf etwas zu verständigen und
nicht darüber zu reden wie man es
bezahlen will also das Geld für den
Sozialausgleich soll ja wenn ich das
richtig verstanden haben aus dem Klima
vorkommen nur natürlich muss die
Koalition aufpassen dass sie den nicht
gleich dreimal verfrühstückt weil da
gibt es ja noch mehr Projekte die daraus
finanziert werden
und wenn man halt einfach mal so die
Rechnung hört was eine energetische
Gebäude Sanierung kostet da ist es ja
nicht getan mit dem Austausch der
Heizung und eine Wärmepumpe ist teurer
als eine Gasheizung sondern für die
Wärmepumpe muss im Zweifel müssen andere
Heizkörper hier oder eine
Fußbodenheizung muss eingezogen werden
das sind wirklich große Summen wo man
schnell bei einer sechsstelligen Zahl
ist und
ich finde das was in dem 16-seitigen
Papier gerade zu dem Thema Heizung steht
über das die Republik ja wochenlang
diskutiert hat und dann steht da sehr
kryptisch ein kleiner Absatz wo meine
Fantasie jedenfalls nicht ausreicht zu
verstehen wie daraus ein konsistenter
Gesetzentwurf werden soll der dann eben
auch in diese schwierige Haushaltslage
die der Kollege Kol gerade beschrieben
hat passen soll ich bin mir auch sehr
sicher dass es da noch ziemlich viele
strittige Debatten gibt und um die Frage
von ihnen von ihm zu beantworten nein
ich glaube nicht dass das gelingen wird
dass man den Menschen so viel Ausgleich
zahlen kann dass für alle die kleines
oder mittleres Einkommen haben diese
Diskrepanz bezahlt werden kann und ich
glaube dass das Versprechen nicht
einzuhalten ist dass man da keine im
Stich lässt werden die Leute alleine da
stehen mit ihren Sanierung wir haben
eine klare Zeit leistet und den drei
Wochen gibt es ein Gesetzesentwurf der
dann durch Kabinett geht der nächste
Koalitionsausschuss der ein bisschen
kürzer werden soll oder das wird er auch
da unten da brauchen wir nicht
diskutieren das ist ja jetzt in der
Ressort Abstimmung und und dann werden
sie Häuser miteinander vereinbaren ins
Kabinett bringen und dann reden wir noch
mal über das nicht vorstellen ehrlich
gesagt das Wichtige ist ja dass es immer
konkret ist angesprochen wurde die
Haushaltssituation wir haben die besten
und aufmerksamsten und glücksten
Zuschauer der Welt und zeigen Ihnen
vielleicht schon mal diese Übersicht
480 Milliarden Ausgaben im vergangenen
Jahr dafür mussten 115 Milliarden
Schulden gemacht werden und dann gibt es
auf der rechten Seite das sehen Sie
schon gibt es Dinge die nicht im Etat
standen corona-hilfen 130 Aufrüstung
Bundeswehr 100
entlastungspakete Wumms und doppelbums
insgesamt Sondervermögen genannt und
sicherlich nicht komplett benutzt und
abgeschlossen aber das riecht nicht nach
einem wirklich großen Spielraum jetzt
noch mal die Frage an die Politik Lars
Klingbeil gleich ist der Finanzminister
dran aber erstmal hören haben wir die
SPD was kann diese regierungstragende
Partei Herr klingen bei den Menschen
versprechen und ist es klug ihnen zu
sagen wir Federn das alles ab und es
wird nicht mehr kosten als eine normale
Gasheizung also es ist genug zu sagen
wir Federn das ab und das haben wir sehr
konkret auch benannt in dem Ergebnis des
Koalitionsausschusses dass wir dafür auf
die Mittel des Klima und
transformationsfonds zurückgreifen
gerade gesagt
180 Milliarden 180 Milliarden drin
es wird jetzt zwischen den einzelnen
Ressorts am Gesetzentwurf gearbeitet die
die Marschrichtung ist klar mit dem
Beschluss des Koalitionsausschusses und
das auch die Erwartungen die ich habe
dass da sehr genau genannt wird wie dann
in den nächsten Jahren weil dieser Umbau
wird ja nicht 24 stattfinden am 24 gilt
es für Neubauten und dann hat man eine
lange Zeit Leiste danach bin mir recht
sicher auch dass Wärmepumpen günstiger
werden auch dadurch dass es diese
marktwirtschaftliche Entwick lung gibt
wir werden in der Situation kommen wo
die Handwerksbetriebe er sich auch
besser auf die Situation einstellen also
da wird es ja eine Marketing Handwerker
da sind und auch die Geräte
Zuwanderungsgesetz noch machen dann wird
das auch noch besser dass wir die
personellen Lücken schließen
keine Sorgen ein Vertrauen darin dass
wir diesen Weg der Transformation auch
gehen und dass wir dafür das Geld auch
richtig einsetzen
sie freuen sich schon
nein ich freue mich nicht aber
wir scheuen uns auch gemeinsam als
Bundesregierung nicht vor den Aufgaben
es ist so wie Herr Koll eben gesagt hat
es ist eine herausfordernde
Haushaltssituation die wir die zuletzt
2010 vielleicht hatten wir haben jetzt
wieder ein sehr hohes Zinsniveau dadurch
fehlen alleine 36 Milliarden Euro
und hier auf 40 innerhalb von von 12
Monaten 36 Milliarden die nicht für
andere sinnvoller Aufgaben zur Verfügung
stehen aber das werden wir hinbekommen
mit Mut und auch Entschlossenheit
konsequente Entscheidungen zu treffen
jetzt sprechen jetzt konkret erstens wir
müssen die Anforderungen also das was
wir bei den Heizungen oder auch bei
anderen Dingen vom Land für den
Klimaschutz und für anderes verlangen
realistisch gestalten
das hängt ja zusammen was fordern wir
welche Standards bestimmen wir und was
passiert dann in der Praxis denken Sie
an den Wohnungsbau wenn man immer mehr
Anforderungen macht dann wird die
Wohnung teurer dann darf man sich nicht
wundern dass die Mieten steigen also wir
brauchen realistische Anforderungen an
die technologischen Standards zweitens
es wird und muss eine finanzielle
Förderung geben da kann es überhaupt gar
keine Frage geben 40% hat der Bürger
schon verstanden aber eine finanzielle
werden eine finanzielle Förderung
selbstverständlich ermöglichen im Klima
und transformationsform hat Herr Habeck
ja gesagt hat der Kollege habe gesagt
wird er die Schwerpunkte verschieben das
Geld steht nicht zur Verfügung jetzt es
muss neu geplant werden das bedeutet auf
anderes wird verzichtet werden müssen
für eine Förderung in der Wärmepumpe das
ist jetzt Verhandlungsprozess im Zuge
Haushalt aber es gibt einen dritten
Punkt der mir wichtig ist Frau
irgendjemand zahlt dafür
also
wenn Sozialdemokraten sagen wir werden
das sozial ausgleichen und es gibt eine
finanzielle Förderung das hört sich
immer danach an ein abstrakter Staat ein
irgendwer zahlt dafür man kann es aber
ganz konkret sagen es sind immer die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger die bezahlen die
Steuerzahler bezahlen und also dem Grund
müssen wir immer auch deren
Belastungsgrenze im Blick behalten und
vor allen Dingen die Weichen dafür
stellen dass in unserem
landwirtschaftliche Prosperität Wachstum
möglich ist wir werden in sehr
schwierige Situationen kommen denn wir
einerseits Transformation mit
finanziellen Mitteln abfedern wollen und
andererseits nicht investieren in die
Bereiche wo auch neue Arbeitsplätze
entstehen neue Firmen gegründet werden
und deshalb müssen wir diese
transformations Agenda die soziale Frage
verbinden auch mit neuen Impulsen für
wirtschaftlicher und jetzt gibt es im
Bereich also im Bereich der Erneuerbaren
Investitionen vornehmen und gerade im
Bereich der ganzen Technologien die da
entstehen dann glaube ich haben wir eine
große Chance dass hier in Deutschland
viele Arbeitsplätze der Zukunft auch
entstehen dass viele Dinge hier
entstehen können an neuen Technologien
die auch exportwelt also Exportschlager
werden können und ich glaube
das ökonomische Wachstumspotenzial auch
der erneuerbaren Energien und hier sind
dann trotzdem die Wünsche der
Kabinettskollegen die jetzt auch schon
Christian Lindner erreichen
die Vorstellung der Eckpunkte des
Bundeshaushalts war für Mitte März
geplant und wurde von Finanzminister
Lindner erstmal verschoben es gibt noch
kein gemeinsames Verständnis für die
finanzpolitischen Realitäten
der Haushalt 2024 soll um rund 50
Milliarden Euro schrumpfen Wirtschafts-
und Finanzminister streiten sich in
Briefen über ihre Realitäten viele
Kabinettskollegen fordern mehr Geld
[Musik]
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius will 10
Milliarden Euro zusätzlich für die
Truppe
Familienministerin Paulus 12 Milliarden
für die Kindergrundsicherung
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach will 8
Milliarden Euro für die Pflege und
Finanzminister Lindner hat für die
aktienrente 10 Milliarden eingeplant
[Musik]
Robert Habeck richtig Schulden Robert
habe ich gesagt es gibt noch andere
Möglichkeiten und Ideen wie Gelder
aufgebracht werden
Lindner das ist jetzt die Frage machen
wir also was glauben Sie welche der
Kollegen müssen mit Einbußen rechnen und
mit einem zurücksetzen ihre Pläne sie
werden sagen das entscheiden wir in vier
Wochen aber hier ist ja der interessante
Punkt von Herrn Vizekanzler zu sagen es
gibt andere Möglichkeiten und Ideen wie
Gelder aufgebracht werden können
haben Sie eine Vorstellung was das heißt
sind da Steuererhöhungen schon
angemeldet bei ihnen Wünsche dieser Art
das nächste Mal laden Sie ein Harbeck
bitte auch ein wenn sie ihn so oft
zitieren müsste eigentlich auch selber
zu Wort kommen dürfen aber klar ist ja
aber klar ist ja das im politischen Raum
diskutiert wird über Steuererhöhungen
oder sogenannte Einnahmeverbesserungen
wie das höflicher heißt oder dass der
Versuch unternommen wird irgendwie über
Umwege neue Schulden zu machen beides
geht mit mir nicht warum nicht wir haben
bereits jetzt die höchste Steuer und
Abgabenquote unserer Geschichte im
nächsten Jahr wird der deutsche
Gesamtstaat zum ersten Mal mehr als eine
Billionen Euro Einnahmen haben trotzdem
reicht es nicht für die Ausgaben das
zeigt doch wir haben einen Ausgabe und
kein Einnahme Problem und auf der
anderen Seite bei den Schulden können
wir ebenfalls nicht weitermachen die
bisher nicht nur auf keinen Aussetzen
der ist nicht nur ist von nicht nur von
der Verfassung nicht erlaubt es wäre
auch ökonomisch nicht klug wenn die
Zinsen so stark steigen dass von vier
auf 40 Milliarden der Kapital Dienst und
bindet dann kann man doch mit dem
Schulden machen nicht weitermachen dann
zahlen wir irgendwann immer mehr Zinsen
und dann strangulieren wir uns